you're I get a chance to share with you
my thoughts for 20 minutes okay for what
it's worth I'm a regular guy I'm an
insurance guy but I I get a chance to
share with you my thoughts and I and I
by the way just so you know I don't
prepare any of this message and one
reason out I'm prepared here's what I
don't prepare not because I can do it
without having to prepare I write a
couple points and I said speak from the
heart and whatever comes out is whatever
comes out and I'm going to tell you
what's on my mind today and hopefully
from there some of you guys will
understand that this is this is truly
not a business only to start a business
to make money
look you need to make millions there's
nothing wrong with it don't ever feel
guilty about making millions but making
millions or tens of millions or some in
the room we're gonna make hundreds and
if you are gonna make billions it's
great if you do something with it if you
don't do something with it it's empty
it's shallow it's draining you die your
task is just a little bit more expensive
it's just a little bit nicer the people
is just a nicer eulogy maybe a couple
celebrities show up and your money is
left behind and it's great all the cars
gets passed on to somebody else the
homes get passed on to somebody else
you're gonna give it to your kids to
your knees to your nephew that's great
it's phenomenal you made a great impact
in the world but I think there's a
little bit more than that you know right
now we're all dealing with election time
right we're gonna be designing a new
president between now and the next time
we have a convention we have a new
president just so you know that between
now and the next time we have our
convention we have a new president and
some of you guys in the room may be
Democrats some of you guys in the room
may be Republicans some of you guys in
the room may be a libertarian some of
you guys may be independent and some of
you guys could give a rat's you know
what about politics it's totally fine
I do think it's important to know what's
going on in the world I do think it's
important to know what's going on with
America I do think it's important to pay
attention to it I do think it's
important to study politics to make
educated decisions I really do think
that that is important for us too
that especially if you have kids I got
two boys and I got one on the way
they're counting on their father to make
the right choices they're counting on
their father to study and make the right
votes they're counting on their father
to vote on the right leader in the House
and Senate in governorship in presidency
in VP and all of that stuff they're
truly counting on me and I take that
very serious one of the leaders earlier
I was walking around and I called a lot
of people out so I should be md's I
stopped coming around the breakout
meeting and one of the guys text me and
said he said Patrick I just want you to
realize man I appreciate you calling me
out but I got this this this this dad
and you know all this stuff he said to
me and I wonder guys I respect the most
I said I want you to understand
something
you don't have to go into the meetings
you don't even have to listen to
anything I'm telling you but I want you
to know one thing when you go to your
city and someone asks you accompany
you're a part of and the first thing
they do they want to go and check the
CEO who your CEO is I want you to know I
don't just say I'm a business owner and
I don't care what you think about me I
can do whatever I do know before I'm a
business owner I chose to be a leader
before being a business owner and to
make a decision to be a leader before a
business owner a business owner you
could do it and it's only about you a
leader you could do it and it's about
the people gainsaid something very
special when he said what's the
difference between a legend and a hero
he said a legend does something
incredible in the world for himself a
hero does something incredible in the
world for others I want you to know the
pure intention of this company is to
give birth to a lot of heroes to make an
impact in billions of people lives
around the world
that's the purpose of this company money
is going to be made Ferraris are going
to be driven Lamborghinis are going to
be owned ten twenty thirty
thousand-square-foot homes are going to
be on traveling all over the world is
going to happen presidents are going to
be at our conventions I was speaking to
one of our guys that said if we have
five thousand registrations next year at
our July convention we could have
Clinton Bush and Michael Jordan at our
convention if we chose to do that we can
have Alicia Keys performing at our
convention
can you imagine Alicia Keys singing fall
in
keep on falling oh my gosh I'll go crazy
woman's worth who knows what I'm talking
about right with all those songs I
visualized it all the time there's only
three songs I heard in my life that I
had to stop my body really shook one of
them was stink Desert Rose remembers
that song ride one when Shep mommy said
what he said and it all of a sudden I
stopped I said what was that all about I
came back from the kitchen I'm broke
living in Granada Hills with my dad my
sisters I'm like who is that guy and
he's doing the whole voice if I do it
right now all guys would walk out but
you know which one I'm talking about
lion and I see I literally stopped the
other one was a white cliff and Carlos
Santana Mario Mario who remembers that
remember how that's a whole different
story right I served out so my goodness
man us a good song and then the other
one was falling with with Alicia Keys
baby I have to tell you that song had a
big impact in my life right that song
was a song anyone remember the first
time I heard Alicia Keys sing fallen our
voices and gellick been it's amazing I
want to sit literally right there and
listen to her sing to all of us three
songs is all I want you know how much
that's worth a quarter million dollars I
want to pay for that can you imagine you
invite people to convention can you
imagine you won by people to convention
and you say how about about our
commission it's gonna be President
Clinton Bush why you having both them
screw we like to confuse ourself we've
brought both of them you know and on top
of that we're gonna have Jordan be there
and we're gonna have Alicia Keys perform
a few songs is this a concert or what do
you guys do we sell life insurance but
come on down bro so Timmy imagine that
invitation right so look look look all
this stuff said and done I started with
politics I told you this stuff I want to
wrap it up here for you to be thinking
about this
politicians are great at selling us
they're very good at selling us I think
media is ten times better than
politicians at selling us and I have
lived in different economic systems I
have I lived in a family where my mother
believed in communism and my father
believed in imperialism
I am gonna be telling this story till
someone stops me from telling this story
you're either gonna have to stop freedom
of assembly to stop this man from
telling this story I am NOT gonna stop
telling this story
I saw Karl Marx and it's book on what he
wrote on what he felt was a perfect
economic system for a country to run
which destroyed Russia and killed 20
million people that's communism and I
watched what capitalism did in America
that made stand-up if you are not
Caucasian stand up if you are not
Caucasian or you were not born in
America stand up look at this I don't
know if you know or not stand up if you
look at this okay stand up if you're not
Caucasian your parents were born in
America stand up if your parents weren't
born in America do you know why you're
in America let me explain to you why
you're in America let me simplify why
you're in America listen to me listen to
me wait hear me out
even the people that don't like what I'm
telling you right now the reason why
you're in America is because of
capitalism the reason why you're in
America is because of free enterprise
the reason why you're in America is
because of the freedom of religion
assembly opinion whatever you want to
sit that's why you're in America believe
it or not that's why you're in America
please grab seats 40 million immigrants
live in America number one country in
the world number two is Russia 11
million people why why is that well let
me say something so hopefully this will
stay with your mind as you hear people
getting up on stage and talking about
the tax system in our tax code system
we're gonna make it 90% and all this
other mess and we need to give all these
programs that are free and it sounds so
noble and young people tend to buy it
because young people haven't yet had a
chance of having somebody who works less
than them take a position over them you
haven't yet been fired or laid off by
somebody who doesn't work that hard who
just has a political power over you that
you got fired and you realize that
wasn't fair wait till that happens to
you what's it that happens to you listen
we still are the greatest country we are
still a capitalistic nation wait wait
but you gotta understand this listen to
me
Reagan met with Gorbachev Russia
switched to capitalism their government
so communism their economic system is
capitalism wait China made a statement
in the world Olympics about nine years
ago if you remember how incredible of an
opening show they do I don't have to
remember that eight nine years ago most
incredible opening show they ever did
they were a communistic nation neither
capitalistic nation they were all about
communism neither about Kaplan why they
can burn in capitalism I went to Panama
Panama is unemployment rate is two point
three percent very capitalistic nation
two point three percent unemployment
everyone in Panama would tell me we
fouled American system because we
believe in capitalism and free
enterprise because it works now here's
the thing to think about what do you
think is harder to do do you think it's
harder to convert a nation who believes
in communism or socialism to convert
them to capitalism or do you think it's
harder to convert a nation from
capitalism to socialism communism which
do you think is harder to do this one or
this one
raise your hand if you say this one
rezian if you say this one raise aeon if
you say this one so you think it's
harder to go from capitalism to
socialism communism let me explain to
you why I say it's this one you don't
have to agree with me but let me make my
case the reason why it's harder to do
this is very simple the moment a parent
continuously gives a thousand two
thousand three thousand dollars to his
kid for five ten 20 years and then that
mom or dad decides to stop these kids
been relying on that money for 10 20 30
years he's already entitled it's very
hard to do but a nation like this who
has had a formula that's worked that's
created the nation trillions of dollars
and all of a sudden we have this money
somebody can't get elected and say all
of this money we have I bet if I start
giving free stuff to everybody they'll
elect me it's so easy to go like this
it's so easy to go like this now here's
the thing some people come back to me
Robert said yesterday says look I do
think the nation needs to have a free
public system or public educational
system I think so I do believe a nation
needs to have a military yeah of course
we need to be free
we need to be safe we need to be pretty
of course they do I think the nation
needs to have some kind of a health care
program sure they do but then where does
it stop
how many guys see a 35 year old still
living with mom and dad and expectant
mom and dad to take care of their money
let me ask you let me ask you what do
you think about that person what do you
think about that person
honesty state the me what do you think
about that person
lazy see all these other names now watch
this watch this
what do you think about a 67 year old
that lives with his son and daughter
what's the problem with that nothing
they pay the price no one is saying
let's not take care of our seniors all
we're saying is the 35 year olds that
want to constantly rely on the system to
take care of them what can I do that
anymore we can't come to give you free
programs you got to get off your butt
and go to work you can trust me relying
on everybody to take care of you you
can't costly expect everybody to give
you a free Poland free house free cars
free daycare free Medicare free off you
can't expect that I don't want you to
expect it from me now Patrick you're
being so cold
what if somebody has some health issues
don't give me the exception of one
percent or one point zero zero one
percent I'm talking about the 95 percent
who I become entitled and I want you to
know this the same way you raise your
kids where you think they need to
eventually get up and go do their own
thing we need to start doing that with
our adults and somebody gets up and
wants to vote and say College needs to
be free high school needs to be free
this needs to be free if you vote me
everything's gonna be free 22 year old
say he's the most noble man in the world
let me vote for him and in 55 year olds
that are creating jobs and here we are
at our company we give the biggest
raisers to our staff minimum this year
we give a 20% race to all of our staff
20% race all of our staff our chief
compliance officers a highest-paid chief
compliance officer in the marketplace
why are we doing that how proud are you
of that by the way hey I'm what was that
now promised you day one he's a
highest-paid shave chief compliance
officer in the marketplace volunteering
they can make a lot of money next year
look at Mario's face when you ask him
about a matter of fact ask Monica about
the RACI god so why does that happen
because it's called capitalism
because if we go to Texas I don't have
to pay the 13 percent I gave them to
raise so when people say all capitalism
is this and all this other stuff
now listen people say cops are bad
people maybe 2 percent of them but I
don't let 98% of people dictate my
opinion about good cops
people say military people kill people
sniper all this other kind of crap I do
not let 2% of people dictate my opinion
about military all pastors all they do
is abuse kids and molest Emma and sleep
with members and I do not let 2% of
pastors dictate my opinion about the 98%
of pastors all parents all they do is do
this to their kids I do not let 2% stop
letting the exception dictate your
opinion about politics economic system
financial system all of these
entitlement programs don't let the 1% to
2% in title and all this stuff that they
sell you on don't let it convince you of
the way you vote don't let it do it but
they're very good at it they're very
good at it they're exceptionally good at
it and unfortunately I only have control
over so many people I can influence vote
by vote wise some of you guys are gonna
City and you're gonna say I think
Hillary's a great person to vote for
something I was gonna say oh my god it's
Bernie Sanders he's amazing feel the
Bern you know I'm saying wolf is amazing
something that's gonna sell for me for
me my guys Ted Cruz I like Ted Cruz
somebody guys been saying I hate Ted
Cruz somebody guys say to Donald Trump I
just love Trump man but I got to keep it
a secret because when I say to my family
they get so irritated but I love Trump
Shh I love Trump my guy is Rubio he's
young he's Hispanic I love the guy bro
look I like your trends I look at who
gets up and says whatever they want to
do to earn my vote that's the person I
don't vote vote for I don't vote for the
person that says anything to get my vote
I have a big problem with that
when Jennifer and I were dating
initially I did not tell her what she
wanted to hear I told her who I was
67 times I asked her are you sure you
want to marry me and she would say why
do you keep asking me that's it because
you don't understand the life I want to
build I want to build an incredible life
I have one shot at this thing you don't
know what my mom and dad did to bring me
to America I don't think you really feel
the brunt of fire in my belly on what I
owe those guys till the day I am buried
all I think about is I got to pay back
my mom and that sacrifice are bringing
me to America I'm gonna do it so when my
wife and I had that conversation
together when my wife and I had that
conversation together then all of a
sudden she says no I'm with you I said
great because I just want you to know
whatever you want is yours whatever you
want is yours but don't expect a
nine-to-five got you married
don't expect a lifestyle of the rich and
famous with a guy coming on my five
o'clock it ain't gonna happen
you want a nine-to-five gotta live in an
apartment there's plenty of guys out
there that's not this guy but I'm gonna
give everything I got I'm gonna take it
very serious to be faithful to you don't
think for a moment guys I'm a man and
you know you understand that men like
women and you understand we're kind of
weird and you understand that men also
have temptations and we have weaknesses
anybody tells you they're perfect and
they're God Jesus those are the people
you want to stay away from because
they're the real ones that have the
problems I get tempted I see beautiful
woman here I see a lot of different
things that happen
I see the conversation sometimes people
say to me in my ear but I'm sorry man my
crusade is much bigger than your beauty
what I want to do my life is much bigger
than that
I can't fall for them and I have a lot
of great friendships in the company lots
of them I have a lot of them by the way
don't don't you wanna understand this I
didn't tell you I'm imperfect any of
that stuff uh don't put me on the spot
being perfect I'm just telling I'm
committed to that woman I'm coming to my
kids my kids expect an incredible father
my kids expect an incredible father to
deliver to to not just love on them all
the time I got a love on them and
sometimes I need to sit down and have
that talk and the most painful thing to
do with your kids sometimes give them a
Papa cause instead of their hand getting
red your hand gets red and I lose sleep
at night I think about a toss and
turning and all this stuff
it hurts me I think about it all day the
next day the following day
it hurts me I am in pain I don't like
the look on their faces but they need to
be leaders when I'm dead one day
they can't just rely on this guy and the
same thing needs to happen with our
economical system where the next
generation can run this country to
continues to be the greatest country in
the world because of the right decisions
you and I made that's what we need to do
so I certainly hope when you hear my
message here by the way just know this
if you're in the room you're someone's
father husband wife auntie the smart
uncle you know the smart uncle that has
a lot of degrees that's broke if you're
one of those guys whatever it's totally
fine you're welcome here as well we have
me we'll have good people here it's
really not the company that we just want
to make money and do all that stuff okay
we cannot help ourselves from talking
about this so if anything I just said is
important to you I just want to
encourage you tonight to realize that
you got to make money the only reason
it's very important make money is to
what are you gonna do with the money the
other reason why it's important to make
money is your microphone gets bigger
people listen to you you have
credibility people tend to listen to
people with money you got to make money
for that reason you gotta have a few
million in the bank you gotta have that
stuff because it validates your voice
your opinion about things they just
listen to you more but I have very
simple vision it's bring him back the
free enterprise system and hope to
American families until the day I'm dead
I'm gonna be talking about this no one
can stop me from talking about this I'm
gonna continuously inspire people and
encourage people and with the help of
our leaders we will continuously
encourage other people to take the risk
of becoming an entrepreneur and
challenge them to step up and realize
the moment you start making money on
your own your dreams will come true
you will look at yourself in the mirror
and say I am so proud of you
your wife's gonna say babe I married a
total stud your kids are gonna say my
dad is my hero my mommy's my hero your
grandkids are gonna talk about you
forever your great grandkids are gonna
have a picture of you on the wall saying
I want to be like my grandma I want to
be like my grandfather and when you're
dead and we're dead in heaven I don't
know if Jesus or God is gonna have you
know why Norn I hope you have some wine
cuz I heard some stories in the Bible he
likes wine
just say he's got wine you're gonna sit
up there and we're gonna be all wrinkled
up maybe you're gonna be young again
with nice muscles I hope they have that
like in you know good gyms it sounds
like everyone's gonna look it so there's
probably not like nice champs and your
guns some of that stuff in heaven we'll
see what's gonna happen we're gonna sit
there and we're gonna say hey bro it's
my kid look look look did you hear what
he just said what'd he say he said he's
proud of his daddy whoa look well my
girl just said what'd she say she said
daddy I'm proud of you Oh doesn't it
just feel good give me a high five
pow that's gonna be heaven for us that's
the life I signed up for which life you
want to sign up for if you want to sign
up for that life let's go change the
world together that's what we want to do
with PHP that's why the leaders here
invited you to come and join us on this
incredible journey with this incredible
company called people helping people
that's what I want to share with you
tonight here before I get into the
announcement so thanks for hearing for
my rant or whatever I just said thanks
for listening to me